or shot or mortar shadowmoor see we can
say it now we'd all fit yourself every
conversation we have like don't say well
don't give it here this dream okay don't
save shadow of mordor Delores did a
great job on that nominee show mad boy
well what happened do you know what one
game in here I know that an Australian
was just on set and I don't have enough
Australian so having two Australians in
a row on that be it Randall family hello
yes really oh hmm your roster I
Australian yeah time I kangaroo down
sport yeah Wallabies and kangaroos what
is it actually know what I'm not gonna
make wall tires jokes anymore no no it's
although that's not done rate anymore
the same way you cut me ya know Bill
Cosby jokes no no no I Wallabies
Wallabies walls are miscible drop bears
they're real thing that's something
that's google it I've been after this
after this after their run up the sky be
okay right no friend what's your
official title here i am the managing
editor suisse of cakes what haha that
didn't come from places of here already
I'm just saying I'm motion over two
weeks out there can you believe they
gave me the title managing editor uh uh
uh uh I'm the guy that prods Kevin I can
other people I don't not only get her
out right because you know Kevin is that
you've given us the guy careful he's my
boss yes we're famous we all prod Kevin
yes oh don't feel you know in different
ways yeah in different times in a day
how much mean they're just like this hmm
sticking my doing some space but of
course we had our long and drawn out and
angry and beautiful and it was very she
& Game of the Year discussion sir you
were kind of the puppeteer of the whole
thing I would say or that may be the
master of ceremonies perhaps yeah yeah I
mean you know I think you guys have sort
of covered it a little bit in sort of
like other videos but yeah you know like
this whole thing starts basically with
the team yes and I'm just basically the
guy who sort of collates all that
information at the start to try and get
us to a good place where we can then
start talking about you know okay what
do we think is actually the best within
each of them
degrees so you know like the place that
we start from basically I just ask
people what their favorite games are ya
for the year and I other things like 20
25 people or so like around the world
including our offices in Australia and I
UK yep and you know basic accolade
although I think we gave us like top 10
or 15 yeah yeah yeah so you know I asked
you guys ok doesn't matter what platform
you know as long as was released in this
time period what are your favorite games
for this year what I do then is I you
know come up with a list I break it all
down you know I assign this you know
arbitrary number school and depending on
work place in everyone's top 10 which is
great if you gave him a list of top 10
games not in order of preference like I
did it was buried in a list of 10 games
when asked for a top ten doesn't rank
them it's so so it was very matter in
the end quote it was very clearly in the
email hey Danny I just want a clump of
10 games right to Susan grab bag yeah I
think I could I think gang beefs was I
want to put at the top and you know what
the gang beasts I looked at anyone yeah
danny has been playing a little game
this year so that's okay I think that's
all right but these were just oh yeah
yeah i tell ya i know it's gross but but
that's only that's like a starting off
yet for discussion yes that doesn't mean
anything that is our kickoff point all
that does is basically tell me ok this
is the these are the games that you know
a lot of people and staff have enjoyed
for the year so what I didn't do is we
all go to this not our first meeting
which is our nominees me yeah right and
essentially from there I just put a list
of I think the top 10 for each category
that you have and then the argument
stuff and I'm the list of kind of the 15
ones it didn't yes Sarah to get in yeah
a couple of those end up getting in yeah
exactly so yes and then that's that's
when you know the discussion starts and
it's free for everyone to say I don't
think they should be in there or you
know we usually try and pick you know
people to champion something for ya so
if it's a game that hasn't been played
that much but you know one person is
particularly passionate about it you
know that that's the platform to start
sort of lobbying for that and you can
see it in games like Fred but we'll get
to the game of your stuff in a second
but for instance on PC like divinity
original saying is not a game that a lot
of people could have put in like 80
hours
you can't just play that game in like
five hours and get the gist you need to
like cook time in so that's one of those
games you could see there were like five
or six people on staff would put quite a
lot of time into that I would realize it
might be contender and then those kind
of conversations came and that's why I
think the game spot decision is is more
than just all of our lists collated it's
more than just one person shouting from
the mountaintop that they love this game
it's kind of this hybrid of the personal
and the collective's because you have
that chance to hear someone speak
passionately about a game and maybe you
make it may be that influences your
decision maybe it doesn't you know but
on the flip side everyone's voice has
already heard even if they are not
comfortable speaking in that environment
because as we've discussed previous on
the show can be sometimes can be
intimidating yes so just all it kinda
helps come bring that all together so
let's get to it then let's have a chat
about some of the games that didn't win
game of the year okay good i might be
saying will be contenders I'm gonna keep
an eye on the game spot shaft on the
twitch chat at Daniel Dwyer on the game
spot charge and if you have any
questions yourself please feel free to
throw them in but just looking at sort
of general chartering gamespot and being
in deliberations as well I wanted to
sort of talk about a couple of games
first of all talking about Chris's sort
of you know the idea of the personal
best against the collective best we had
a ten at a ten this year I usually the
first question Bayonetta 2 why doesn't
paint it to automatically win Game of
the Year cab it's an even when we it
didn't yes yes I mean a lot of that
comes down to first of all just the
obvious personal taste um so in that
sense um you know obviously mark loved
Bayonetta 2 and it's hard to argue in
some ways against a 10 out of 10 for
this game I played it made my personal
top 10 list but everybody but there's
also the aspect of a game having more
meaning to an individual person than it
does to the collective right and even
those of us who who played bayonetta 2
there are still games that resonated
more for all sorts of different reasons
and ultimately you know we we end up
sort of going with some of those games
that resonated more for all you know in
this case you know you can make the
argument for Bayonetta 2 being perhaps a
perfect action
but it's also a whole lot like Bayonetta
one and I you know it's you know there
are all sorts of things to talk about
you know and it's not just about how
it's not just about you know whether a
game doesn't do things that are wrong
but it's about do the things that right
how much do they really matter and the
it's interesting that like like you said
the wii u category was one actually by
mario kart 8 and so many people had
played both of these games and then what
often happens in these discussions as we
say okay who's played both and then
argue sort of what your perspective is
on this and it yeah it's funny I think
most people even even mark obviously a
massive fan of Bayonetta 2 he also said
when he was here a month ago I'd have no
problem with mario kart 8 winning we won
as well because the UK office plays it I
think every day after working out at
this stage and I guess it's important
that I like Chris did mention it like
you know we have to delineate like what
our reviews are which is in at the end
of the day like you know a personal
opinion that were you know the game spot
is you know is backing versus our game
of the year which you know really is
more of a group reflection you know of
what we felt was the best so yes you
know there are gonna be instances where
you know a game that has scored higher
is somehow beaten by you know a game
that was you know that was you know not
as not as rated as favorably but you
know and bayonetta obviously stir is a
good example of this but you know when
we got to this stage and you know we you
know everyone in the room started
talking about their favorite wii u
experiences for the year we just kept
coming back to mario kart 8 yeah there
wasn't even a question really like when
it came down to it and that's that's
part of the power of the collective
right yeah you know we you know we a
voice arises and eventually the the
chorus clearly is singing at one
particular tomb and in this case that
was the particular tune but that's not
anything new in game sports history I
mean typically actually the the game of
the year isn't the highest soccer game
of the year I mean that's that's nothing
new at all you are going back to like
when you mentioned EverQuest oh yeah pc
for example that game certainly was not
the highest scoring game of that year
but it's certainly a worthy one and part
of that too is in Game of the Year
discussions you know we really do
project ourselves ahead a little bit and
it's like really seriously when we look
back on this year what really is going
to be the
meaningful game in this particular
category and when we got down to I guess
the the the brass tacks of talking about
what was going to win a game of the year
and it kind of came down to three games
to really but let's talk about that
third one which was talked about a
little bit of it as well which was
divinity original sin yeah and what
about that game do you think made it a
contender and one of the top like
handful best games of the year and what
ultimately do you think is the reason
why we didn't pick it I guess I can
speak to that right because I played
tons of divinity of both well I play it
what's great is I actually all three
games like I reviewed all three games
come to think of it let's not talk about
what the third one is just yet oh
alright ourselves i'm sorry i'm sorry so
divinity but it does so happen that i've
played all of these games to completion
so i may be unique in that in that
respect divinity is a really special
game and i think i noticed when i was
looking at our pc game of the year
winner page which obviously divinity
original sin was the winner of that
particular category i was looking at it
and and somebody in there says gosh that
looks an awful lot like last year's
gamespot pc game of the year which was
path of exile yeah and yet those games
are absolutely nothing alike and i think
that says a lot about divinity honestly
and because people look at this and you
mean it's up on the screen now you look
anything oh it's an overhead perspective
you know old school looking RPG right oh
I've played baldur's gate or I've played
whatever this doesn't look anything new
man you are just so totally wrong about
that and that's that's what's wonderful
about this is it proves that you can
have so much depth and have so much
actual I've never really a big fan of
the word innovation because sometimes we
use that kind of improperly but it's a
really innovative game with lots of
interesting things and the fact that it
merges the familiar with the unfamiliar
is one of its greatest in a moment to
moment in in divinity is so impactful
you know like every every combat
encounter like nearly every decision you
make possibly has a lot larger
ramifications and you know like like
every single battle like I played in
divinity was tense
not actually had to plan it through
because you could die you can die at any
single battle in that game and you know
for me it made it you know a really
compelling thing yeah every every move
you make is an event like everything is
an event it's just not like oh I played
for 30 minutes in si habla like I just
kind of slept through it and clicked in
whatever it's like no everything you do
it's an event and everything has a
consequence even when you you don't
expect the consequence but then when it
happens it's like oh yeah I shall should
totally have seen that coming well
regardless of its constant giving of
events in combat divinity original sin
and was kind of a it came up in
conversation a lot of games kabob
conversation we gave every game its
share i remember there being a sort of a
good 15 minutes where we talked about
destiny in terms of it didn't win any
platform categories but we still talked
about in a relationship like its impact
with a large contingent of people here
at gamespot who were playing it today
still and and so many people involved
into deliberations but ultimately this
big chew out at the end was between the
eventual winner middle-earth chatter
Mordor and Dragon Age Inquisition and
Chris why do you think we picked Mordor
/ Inquisition what about Inquisition do
you think sort of left just was just not
enough to pip game of the year I mean I
think part of it is sort of the
realities of the kind of experiences
people are going to be able to have and
this is why we sort of goes back to that
balance of the personal versus the
collective like to get I think I gotta I
gotta I'm engrossed in dragon age
currently but I'm played about 20 hours
of that game now when I play 20 hours of
shadow of mordor that is a signal like a
significantly larger percentage of that
game then it is of Dragon Age
Inquisition and the kinds of things that
I'm seeing the kinds of bonds that I'm
building the kinds of combat scenario
scenarios I'm getting into you know are
you know they change as you sort of go
throughout the whole game I think that
part of the things that I don't know
dragon age like was is it the kind of
thing where you you know we know it we
know Bioware it's sort of a known
quantity Rio how they do these
relationships and the god they do them
well and like the discussions and the
the interplay you can have is
fascinating and engrossing but it's also
you know it's
it's a crop on to some extent yeah it is
it is familiar in a way yeah I think
Kevin sort of stated at best I mean you
came up with this in like our winners
deliberation meeting that you know
dragon age is an amazing game an
outstanding game but you know shadow of
mordor and mr. system is the is the
thing that people are going to be
copying and I think you can send out
with with Michael onset you know just a
few minutes ago too so you know I guess
we wait both of those things right like
you know I guess in the in the fullness
of time what are we gonna look back on
and say this game had you know an impact
you know over and above you know like it
was an outstanding experience for that
year and you know I think in the end at
the end that's for me anyway that's what
tip model / did the other two games you
mentioned divinity and and dragon age
the funny thing I found during those
deliberations was that there was no two
camps on this I feel like people were
wavering constantly I feel like there's
a lot of talk about dragon age
inquisition and then people going you
know and then the some person would
remember an instance from Mordor and say
you know this and then I remember there
was individuals sort of swapping which
one they wanted to be on and it was a
nightmare in the end like it was there
was so believe it took two or three
votes on this if we did and would change
every single time we don't focus on
people who like I mean we try not to
take the the votes aren't like to be all
either it's more of the like do we think
this is what it is yeah let's just do a
round table to make sure we continue on
this discussion part you know yeah and
the thing that got to me about Mordor
was that we kept talking about and the
Nemesis system and it being like a
wonderful way to that sort of a new
mechanic and sort of like ultimately it
makes that world so much more
interesting because instead of just
doing you know picking where you want to
go in the map like say other games in
that jar like and from the second sonica
made this year it's like a smorgasbord
of stuff that you can do if you want
pick which thing you want to do level up
and then go to that area whereas in this
one you could be picking what you wanted
to do with in the game we go no I'm
gonna throw that guy in he's too
overleveled for you you're gonna have to
run away or you're gonna have to fight
him you're looking for a green guy you
know it throws you curveballs constantly
and the other thing which I think maybe
ultimately we started talking about in
relation to these two games was that
mortar is just kind of solid like combat
wise i had
he enjoyed a combat that game far more
than I have in the past couple of say
you know Assassin's Creed games or
whatnot the world exploring it's not
incredibly varied or massive leave a sex
car but it's always interesting and the
level design of like the various
strongholds and stuff is super varied
and it's almost because it's so good and
because all that stuff just kind of
works you forget about it so it's the
Nemesis system that keeps popping up
it's like well that's what makes it
stand out actually the game is kind of
solid across the board yeah just those
individual islands mean you mentioned
the gating like you come to a place
where you think oh I'm just gonna waltz
in and do whatever oh no there's the big
dude and as others I can't do this after
all and that's I mean that's that's
basically like the developer keeping you
out of a place but not actually
arbitrarily limiting you and that's
that's actually really hard to do and
something we take for granted they're
all sorts of things in games we take for
granted that we only notice when they're
done poorly you know all sort of things
like sound design is one of those things
you really only notice not a soundtrack
sound when it's but it's bad you only
notice collision when it's bad you know
and so that that's the great thing about
motorist it has all these things all
these solid things that we can take for
granted because they're all just
fantastic and that's the way it should
be we shouldn't have to think about this
thing I think this year was also
instructive enlightening honry how some
series that have nailed those things for
years you take advantage of it like it
once you like realize once it's not
there it's oh my god oh it's a part like
Assassin's Creed and halo the two games
that technically have always been you
know pretty solid bets and both gabes
end up being like massively
disappointing because of technical
issues and it all you know and that's of
course that's disappointing but it def
it is like it's like it's almost good to
be reminded in a harsh way that like
yeah like Michael said making video
games is oh my god the amount of effort
it takes to make this stuff and then
yeah we have these moments in our
discussions where we're just like
tearing down the best of the best games
just trying to find that articulation
between them it's it's with one of
things that makes those discussions like
really intense and kind of a bummer
sometimes speaking of which I want to go
to some of the questions because they're
coming in at
sy sy oh sorry no Krabby Prime asks what
was the biggest or most violent
arguments the staff got into Oh heart
from Andy Bowman screaming that Forza
horizon 2 should be game of the year I
mean quite honest the the one is sick
said to me is the the very passionate
arguments we had around destiny oh yes
yes absolutely because there was a lot
of conversation about whether it should
be even a nominee yes in the first place
and I know that you know like the keys
destiny people in our team were you know
we're very very passionate and you know
like spoke very eloquently about why
this game should be there and we also
had a couple of the centers as well
write about you know destiny being in a
mediocre game the only 11 were only that
you you people are crazy I get what you
like it but that game is a real dumb
shooter it's interesting I mean I mean
we when Jeff was talking about World of
Warcraft yeah a lot of that kind of was
hitting home about destiny and and I you
know and and I so I want to give destiny
credit because I think regardless of how
you feel about destiny it's it's maybe a
lot easier for me to see some of its
drawbacks because I've been playing you
know MMOs for forever hmm arm and so I
look at destiny and I underst I
immediately see like the places where it
disappoints and the the places you know
the various things but for a lot of
people the eye in the office the idea of
like even a raid these are people who
have never done a raid before the out of
cases they've never you know so for you
know so you have destiny a game that for
better for worse is the one that's
showing them this world that they've
never really been invited into before
because they don't play that that type
of game and now and that was one of the
impassioned arguments that someone made
a destiny made them into a you know
someone who enjoys multiplayer you know
before like would shoot there were
always you know just a solo guy but
destiny was the first game that actually
pushed them and made them enjoy you know
the social aspect I ran that it's
interesting you talk about the sort of
unique personal experience because one
of the questions just as coming from a
soon is did I ever argue for transistor
and or did it remain exclusive to my
personal list so transistor our personal
top fives aren't on the side
I think mine's going up on Christmas Eve
but you know it's in the top five anyway
it's one of my favorite games of the
year yep but it's not a game but it's
not a game that I would have liked
argued for Game of the Year you know
outright we're there any games that you
guys enjoyed that will like be on the
top of your game of the year list but
that like you never would have suggested
for our top 10 the ones that were that
the one was at the top of my top
personal top five is the one I went to
bat for and okay I held forth on for
sure because like like this is my
seventh game of the year deliberation
like I'm very comfortable like I have
this opinion on this game and I can like
articulate it really well let me do that
thing that Jeff was talking about and
makes itself large and put my you know
and like bring people into my experience
with the game which is powerful but of
course has its drawbacks I but you I
mean you were you were in there for
transistor but then you also realize
like because it was a nominee on the
platform on PlayStation 3 3 or 4 right
but you know you sort of also realized
like when is when to push and when like
yeah it deserves a push and when it
feels right and when to just be unlike
nominees like we battle over nominees
that's an honor to be nominated and like
having having transistor there I don't
know it seemed to me like you regarded
that as like that was giving it your
your your diligence your life like here
I know the reason why I love that game
so much is that that is a genre that has
eluded me personally for quite a long
time I've never really gotten into those
sort of I guess what would you call him
like character or PGs or whatever were
that sort of isometric strategy game
like I never played any of those games
and everybody got into it before so I
knew that that's why it was important to
me and what I think you'll often find
when we go to like comments on you know
the comments for the video on this one
it goes on youtube or on gamespot is
that people know what their favorite
game is but when you're in a room it's
like trying to like pick as you know the
Christmas tree with your family you're
never going to get the one you want you
have to like have this color it totally
changes how you sort of perceive quality
when you talk about a group instead of
like your personal one but the personal
ones are usually very clear like for me
it was pokemon like it isn't on my top
one but it's in my top five and I would
you know
I have had many argues with people in
this in this organization about the
merits of Pokemon and you know it was
going to be a futile I to try and push
that across the line but you know like I
know why I enjoying that I enjoy that
game yeah you know I try and articulate
it and usually buff yeah yeah I'm a
Jigglypuff guard right so and you know I
like I know lord knows Kevin I've tried
to bring you across with me but you
haven't crossed I haven't crossed the
dark side yet but there's also something
else in there too and I think that's
just you know as people who have done
this for so long I think we all have an
instinctive understanding of the
difference between the thing that is
best and the thing that is the thing we
like the most yeah and you know for
example in previous years for example I
Deadly Premonition is one of my favorite
gain of the outgoing generation but the
idea of standing up in a room and
passionately defending a kind of broken
game to be called game of the year we
kind of the idea of that flabbergast me
and yet anybody that's played Deadly
Premonition understands what i'm talking
about that that game I mean calling it
is absolutely possible to call that a
personal ten out of ten yeah absolutely
possible to call that game a personal
one out of ten like there's no way I
would have because I I understood that
it's not really deserving of that kind
of honor or ninja ninja blade which is
another game from previous years I just
love Ninja Blade the idea of standing up
at a room and trying to argue that for
being nominated for game of the years
ludicrous teen but yeah I mean this year
I just not just say you didn't make
impassioned arguments for both of those
games in other cabin other things like
that for music I'm actually yeah you can
chance your arm a bit like trying to
squeeze a little bit this year I i'm
trying to think of something that there
I had known ninja blade or deadly
premonition really for me it's like I'm
not like cannon brawl is in my top five
on I didn't try and push it into top pc
game because i know like not enough
people at experience and I think the
reason I like this because I grew up
playing worms and write something that's
not to take anything away from these
games it but it is yet is to
contextualize what it means for a game
spot to give an award and what it means
for Daniel Dwyer to give an award and
and I think that having meet [ __ ]
haven't got nobody's nobody's getting a
secret out of Daniel Dwyer wards see if
how different 2 turns up anytime soon yo
this game is already your face on a pack
shot I feel boyfriend is a sure thing oh
but I oh gosh what was I thinking about
i will say that there are a couple games
that i feel maybe didn't get there dude
just because of not enough people
playing them I night so I would throw it
like the vanishing of Ethan Carter is
one of those games Michelle McKenna's
reverse of course is not working at
Collinwood yeah he champion that game
and I champion that game on his behalf
but they're obviously there came a point
where on your right my bad because I
love the holidays it's in my and it's my
third favorite game of the year like
it's in my top five and of course of
this war of mine is another game that I
think you know maybe deserve more dude
than then we ever managed to really to
really give it but I also have other
stuff on my top ten that I you know like
fantasia music evolved I think like five
people played that game besides me but I
guess why would a lot of video games
came out in 2014 and it's hard to play
more but we had a massive meta people
involved in those discussions and I
think it's pretty anonymous we're all
super pleased with the winner
middle-earth shadow of Mordor so if you
have any ideas on what you think should
have been gay m'dear you have any
questions at all feel free to put them
in the comments on the video on-demand
version of this here video